foreign
[Music]
it's okay come on
gotcha
I know you're okay that heart's a
beating
stay in there he read his sign
good morning good morning Val hi what
did you bring these are a couple fish
that were in our fish tank the boys are
disassembling it because they're getting
chicks so we're moving the fish out of
the tank so the chicks can move in
they're getting baby chickens awesome
all right let's get them in our tank
[Music]
warm up for Aaron she likes to come back
here and play me playing basketball is
basically how Aaron and I met
we used to go to the gym at lunchtime a
bunch of guys and all of a sudden Aaron
walks in and
I said wow I got to meet her and so I
laid my butt off
I tried to do everything on the court I
could and win her over and I must have
worked because if we went out for lunch
and the rest is history
but I got to keep my skills in line
because
you can still beat me
[Music]
they're very Zen fishies and they'll
make everybody calm oh wait hold up we
started with two black fish we have
Mike's another ten black fishies in here
Caitlyn you did not tell me that there
was fish sex going on in the day
obviously Mama fish she's pregnant again
what a step away from the tank it's got
some sort of fertility water in there we
already have our hands full with the
boys our family is complete thank you
very much
this was our moment of morning
meditation now let the crazy begin
[Music]
pillow guys
you're here for a Coggins test right
Marilyn I had to bring Tucker down for
his Coggins test and health exam because
he'll be traveling to Arizona with me
for the winter and that is a legal
requirement that you have to have your
horse examined before you go out of
state
so a Coggins test is a layman's term for
eia or equine infectious anemia and that
is a disease that we've done pretty darn
good about getting rid of eradicating
and that small box exactly we just don't
want it to rear its ugly head again and
so that's why we keep testing we just
have to draw some blood and then they do
the test in a lab that we send it off to
okay I always hold off the vein below
towards the heart so the blood's coming
around through his head and this is on
the way back to the heart right here so
I'm going to just ease it into the vein
and he felt that a little bit but he's
such a good boy he didn't care
and I need about that much for my blood
tube in addition to blood work I need to
do an overall health assessment that
includes temperature pulse and
respiration so we can clear them for
travel temperature was normal 98.9
actually so that's good
all right Tucker I like what I'm hearing
got a nice strong heartbeat it's normal
Rhythm I don't hear anything down in his
lungs that would make me think that he's
got a pneumonia or anything infectious
down there I just want to look over his
nostrils really well
he's got just a little bit of
oh what'd you say tucker
I think he might have something
I knew he was gonna do that do you look
at her I think he's got some allergies
yeah he looks good got a little bit of
an allergy issue and you have some
medication I do take care of that some
antihistamines and Tucker maybe you know
the warm Desert Air will will help cure
that too you pass for what I say today
but we have to wait on that Coggins test
to make sure it's negative as soon as we
get that Coggins test back we can write
your health paper for wherever you want
to go in the United States okay
[Music]
looks like he has some scrapes here on
his ears is he in with some litter mates
yep
these are like the most amazing chew
toys aren't they they're like tug of war
hello Dan how's it going Dakota it's
going how are you good so you have a new
friend here huh yeah I do this is a
pretty cool day at our Clinic we've got
Dakota and he brought in his new
basilisk lizard
hey Rex you've already named him yeah
his name is Rex because he looks like a
dinosaur this lizard is nicknamed the
Jesus Lizard because they can run across
the water they Scurry along with their
hind feet and that's just something we
don't see every day but they're hard to
care for and aren't for everyone so this
is a real treat I acquired him from
somebody who didn't have the means to
take care of the animal anymore it was
just in horrible conditions I'm going to
do the best I can to give it a better
life from the three days that I've had
it it's made remarkable changes he was
all brown completely Brown it's gotten
green and has black stripes when a
person isn't feeling well we're a little
bit pale or discolored and really the
same thing is true in lizards I wonder
if he wasn't in enough water in his
previous enclosure having a little bit
of issue because he wasn't you know
hydrated enough or soaking enough is
everything else all right how's he
eating for you he hasn't ate in three
days that I've had him that's not a good
thing I would like to really check in
his mouth for stomatitis a common
problem is stomatitis mouth rot is
another name for that and that could be
why he's not eating okay well I don't
know how he's going to respond I just
want to get this near his mouth right
there
got it can you hold him easy easy easy
easy easy easy guy
there's a couple little white spots
but in my opinion it looks pretty normal
I think a lot of the things we're seeing
here are just basically stress things
right I do think getting him to eat is
going to be a trial and error thing do
meal worms do crickets do different
types of food for them that would be
great we got to catch him up on his
vitamins right and then he'll start
feeling better but sounds like you're
well on the way thank you I'm glad that
I brought him in here I am too
[Music]
there we go
say ah
what are we doing with these goats
anything they're just here for the show
that's Harry and Larry Harry and Larry
and Larry I've never worked cattle with
goats right alongside me ever
there's always a new first experience
you guys seriously no this is bad for
you don't
oh look at you
um
I guess
questions
I've got a little dog that's been taught
by a big dog I'll be right there Dr
Aaron we have an emergency is she okay I
have no idea
she's gonna be all right guys
I'm here today because my seven-year-old
dog Lola got in a fight with a larger
dog there can be lacerated vessels
punctured lungs vital organ damage there
can be just Carnage
this is the spot I'm most worried about
here
we have this bite wound here on the side
another puncture up here
we've got him under her jaw here I want
to make sure we didn't get it into the
chest
dog definitely has some pretty major
lacerations around its neck and its
torso if those teeth penetrated her body
cavity that turns this dog from stable
to critical do you want to hold on to
her for a minute we're going to get some
pain medicine the one I'm most concerned
about is the side of her chest but I do
want to take a quick x-ray of that chest
and see each of our lungs is basically
like a big blown up balloon inside our
chest so if the other dog bit Lola hard
enough to pop the balloon that means
that lung can't expand and she won't be
able to breathe you can need a few
stitches I just want to make sure she's
stable enough to sedate her so I know
sweetheart
Lola is the sweetest dog in the world
she'll lick your face she loves
everybody and she's a great cuddler my
daughter really likes to cuddle with her
at night time what's your name
okay Kaylee I'm Dr Aaron is this your
puppy dog
okay these are super tiny needles this
is going to give her some medicine so
she doesn't feel so ouchy all right it's
all right Lola
hey
it's okay
it's okay girl okay there we go that
scared me are you okay yeah all right
you're okay hon
he's lost like two pets okay so like
he's really sad he's pretty sad
it's okay we got her some medicine so
she doesn't feel so ouchy okay
I'm trying to get these kiddos calmed
down because all of their crying and
emotion is kind of feeding into Lola
she's really nervous these are her kids
who she loves and only takes care of her
and so she's getting really anxious
because they're anxious and I need to
get her calmed down so I can get her
into x-ray to make sure we don't have
bigger problems
[Music]
she looks pretty stable but I want to
make sure that we don't have what we
call a pneumothorax or outside air
that's getting into the chest and not
allowing that lung to expand so we see
that that means we have to move much
much more quickly and get this dog into
surgery to fix this hole
oh my gosh Val
we have this bite wound here on the side
another puncture up here we just had a
dog come in after a fight with a bigger
dog I've got her an x-ray now to see if
this bite wound on her chest actually
punctured her lung
everything looks pretty darn good but
she's got to get sewn up tonight
good news guys the X-ray is not showing
that we have any puncture into the chest
so her lungs are going to be okay
she just was really a lucky dog feel
better now yeah it's less for us a
millimeter any direction could have been
completely catastrophic
we'll get everything ready and then take
her to surgery okay
very glad she's all right very thankful
we're going to clip and clean all of
these wounds and then we're going to
basically power wash them with sterile
saline and then we still have any debris
or material I'm going to trim that away
and then lastly we're going to put them
together
all right now we fix up doggy
I'm gonna get all this fatty tissue out
of the way
to make sure we don't have any hair in
there
she has four punctures on the underside
of her neck a large puncture on her side
so that's five and then three more along
the back of her neck so six seven eight
she definitely got picked up in
shook it's really a controlled brush
here I want to make sure she's stable
but in the same breath the longer that
these wounds are open to the environment
we're picking up contaminants or
bacteria
[Music]
I do think this is going to need a
little drain oh the good poke dog got
her real good there when there are
wounds where the skin or muscle has been
pulled away it makes a pocket where
fluid likes to set up if these were to
get infected and we closed them it makes
a perfect place for an abscess to form I
put a drain in there so any of that
fluid will have a way to get out
these are all right over her jugular
vein right here she's got four punctures
that the dog had her by the throat When
Animals Fight they generally go for the
neck region that's totally instinctual
the fact that there's four big punctures
there and we didn't have any flesh torn
open and any major vessels I mean that's
lucky
Dog's real real lucky
next time you gotta run faster than that
big dog
[Music]
Hi Marilyn how are you
looks like you got Tucker right there
with you I do
I'm glad he's there I wanted him to hear
the news too okay
[Music]
his blood test came back as Coggins is
negative
I can write the health paper now and you
guys can cross state lines and go down
to Arizona
bye-bye take care of her Tucker
[Music]
thank you
oh no no okay stay still what are you
guys up to it's a little pandemonium in
here this morning we've got Laura
Stewart bringing a calf in that's about
four or five days old it's a pet calf
it's out of a pet cow that their
daughters have it has not nursed yet
they had tried to milk the heifer and
bottle feed it but the calf really
didn't suck too much not doing well
amidst all this we also have a couple
Farm cats our Dental's waking up here
all right well we'll just Tag Team all
this stuff we'll get through it
[Music]
Laura just pulled up I'm gonna go get
the calf we don't
we know them really well cute little
white calf they are very passionate
about their cows can she walk yes and
they are excellent caretakers but when a
newborn calf isn't nursing that's a
critical situation her name is Iris oh
she's from a good show Mama she's just
really got to make it I mean it's Eva's
calf there's just a really good
relationship and bond between the two of
them and she means a lot to our family
so we want to make sure she gets the
best start she can other than being an
adorable calf it looks terrible she just
hasn't been sucking very well she's kind
of gone downhill yesterday and then
today no energy she's walking around in
kind of a stupor she looks a little too
skinny yeah let me listen to these lungs
quick
foreign
there's crackles there's wheezes there's
fluid sounds in her lungs
was that a cough yes definitely got
pneumonia setting up
and that heart is just beating terribly
loud and Fast let's draw some blood on
her and just make sure she got enough
colostrum
we can test the blood right here in the
clinic and get immediate results
calves are born with zero immunity to
anything they rely on that first milk or
colostrum to thrive fight off infections
so if they don't receive that in about
four to eight hours after birth things
really start shutting down on them until
almost always they die
at this point we need to treat the
symptoms we need to get some antibiotics
and do her as soon as possible to some
anti-inflammatories into her too
the heart is just pounding
I think she's actually having trouble
breathing
where's that oxygen at her
[Music]
the oxygen is going to calm her down
come on get your air
she won't feel like she's suffocating
all right I'll be right back guys I'm
gonna go check and see if she got enough
colostrum
[Music]
so this is a refractometer if the calf's
total protein reading is less than five
that means it didn't absorb enough
colostrum in the first few hours of life
that means it didn't pass the colostrum
test
take a look at this
oh
[Music]
poor baby
all right I'll be right back guys I'm
gonna go check and see if she got enough
colostrum we've got a pretty sick little
calf in here
take a look at this
oh
I see a serum protein of 4.7 that's what
I came up with too that's not good no it
isn't we know for sure that she did not
receive enough colostrum and that means
that she has to have plasma plasma
should really help replenish all those
immunoglobulins that she just needs you
know to fight off all these infections
yeah
this is like liquid gold going into
iris's vein and it's kind of like
transplants in people and we just have
to make sure that Iris doesn't reject
this plasma
looks like she made it through this
whole transfusion just fine
I would like to keep her overnight
tonight just so we can make sure she's
drinking
she looks better already amazing with
some protein and immunoglobulins can do
yep
hi Lola
oh look at that smile it's been 24 hours
since Lola came in after a bigger dog
attacked her and she seems to be
recovering well
you go how you moving you
look if you want to come see me well
these under her neck look really good
you know she's got some swelling here
but that's to be expected I think she
dodged a big bullet big teeth big teeth
I'm gonna be tied up with a cat surgery
so Val's going to send her home for me
[Music]
there she is
hi little girl
she was one lucky dog I know it she was
really lucky she had a total of eight
puncture wounds she did place a suture
where that drain was placed on this left
side Dr Aaron put it there to help with
some of the drainage she didn't want
that open pocket to develop any extra
fluid so that's why the wrap is on too
to help keep that all together now I'm
just gonna be overprotective of her
thank you guys very much I really
appreciate it take good care of her we
will hi Miss Lola
[Music]
he's playing around now
okay if you lick it while I squeeze it
I'm gonna get your tongue look at him
he's eating his old toenails Zeus that's
weird
got him
Iris the sickly calf got a plasma
transfer this morning and now she's got
a few visitors
[Music]
there's a lot of stuff going on here
with her sinuses and respiratory and I
wonder if when she starts to nurse it
actually is strangling her because she
just can't breathe yeah the other thing
is she could just be going through some
dysphagia do you guys know what that
means
dysphagia means they don't quite know
how to eat right or nurse that sure
could have been why she didn't get right
up and latch on and get that colostrum
yeah
[Music]
gonna get up for us
well that's a good sign she got up and
she said I'm ready to go home and I said
no you're not Iris we still need you one
more night
she didn't get control of that tongue
yeah she's just keeping that tongue off
to the left a little bit more needed
it is very frustrating to deal with the
calf with dysphagia we're going to just
have to put it right in the tuber and
put it right in her stomach if calves
aren't nursing they still need that
nourishment they still need that milk
and the only other way to do it if
they're not going to do it themselves is
to put it right there in that stomach I
feel two tubes I feel the trachea in the
front and the esophagus is where our
tube is
flip it over
There She Goes
no more is going in so that means your
stomach's full take it straight down and
pull it out
that's it and that's how you prevent
them from aspirating right there
she needs to move around and get some of
that yucky stuff that's in her lungs
loosened up and she'll cough it out
[Music]
no that's not Mommy
it's big and white
she has to nurse here before she gets to
go home hopefully she gets it figured
out and gets back to Mom I'm sure they
miss each other
oh Iris better get better sweetheart
[Music]
what is that for deworming good boy
oh it doesn't like my treats today he
likes Donuts better oh he likes Donuts
better I've got donuts too
[Music]
December
oh yeah that's better try some jelly on
there
yeah oh he loves jelly donuts just as
much as I do
[Music]
hi guys is this Z yes all right I'll
have you guys head over straight to exam
room two
he is a yellow lab she's 12 years old
she is a camping dog she loves to sniff
around the fire when we're cooking she
loves to swim she sleeps with me every
night oh hi guys hello I'm Dr Aaron hi
hi oh look at your great face so I hear
Zia is here for a lump
sweet girl
okay
holy smokes
wow Zee you're sprouting a new dog back
here
oh my God and it's oozing there's
definitely an open sore starting here
I've got moisture on my hand from
touching that is that new you know I
noticed that yesterday on the deck when
she got up I saw a wet spot is this
causing quality of life issues we took
her out to the lake last weekend like
trying to throw the ball and she gets
excited that the ball is going to be
thrown and then she turns out really
running anymore oh she won't run it okay
Z is really like the town right below
the dam when it's about to break she
doesn't know what's about to hit but if
we don't do something with this lump
life as she knows it will be over you
know at this point with it starting to
ooze
a decision has to be made here pretty
soon because that's going to start to
get infected and that will get much more
difficult to manage
we just need to do some Diagnostics do
some x-rays some blood work and we'll
reconvene with all the information and
come up with a plan for okay there's not
a limit to what I would do to make sure
that she is as happy as possible and
whatever's best for her job Caitlin
we're going to fill this syringe the
blood that we're getting from Z is going
to let us know if she's even a surgical
candidate to start with it's going to
check her chemistry her CBC or complete
blood count her organ function good girl
open the lump I'm drawing sample cells
from Z's tumor to see if it'll give us
an idea of the tumor's makeup but the
real deciding factor will be how all
these tests combine to give us a full
picture
not bad not bad one of our liver enzymes
is a snitch High let's go see if x-rays
give us any more answers all right muzzy
we're gonna check her chest we'll do a
right lateral left lateral abdomen
whole thing right there
there's a big mess in her belly
well that complicates things Missy
so that whole thing right there is a big
mass in our belly
we just finished x-raying z a 12 year
old Labrador Retriever with a huge tumor
on her leg now we also just found a
large mass in her belly
[Music]
with you guys she missed you
the good news is that
is that actually looked really pretty
great I did take fine needle asperts of
the lump but they were really
inconclusive her x-rays on the other
hand show that we have a tumor in her
tummy so the organ that is right here is
the spleen and you can see how it's very
enlarged
the tumor we most commonly see in the
spleen especially in older dogs is
called the hemangiosarcoma which is a
form of cancer
that complicates things obviously
my biggest concern with her right now is
that this tumor is starting to leak that
is only going to get dramatically worse
so options for you guys option one let's
do what we can to alleviate this big
tumor get it off make her comfortable so
she can enjoy the rest of her time with
you the surgery in and of itself is is
going to be a big surgery I'm not gonna
lie it's very vascular she has an older
dog we have a mass on our spleen that we
don't know if it's gonna affect things
or not all of which UPS the risk second
option would be to say we don't want to
do that let's provide Hospice Care let's
not put her through any surgery and we
help you say goodbye so that she doesn't
suffer
so what do you guys think
I think we should have the mass taken
off you do I think so if she were a
healthy young dog the surgery in and of
itself is a lot are you going to be okay
if she develops signs of metastatic
cancer and you've done all this she's
just gonna get
worse you know if we leave it okay well
I'm game to try it I'm on board with you
guys I support you guys 100 in that you
want to take her home bring her back
tomorrow that would be maybe best
we're definitely going to go take her
for a walk out by the lake which is her
favorite place to be
love honor a lot if something were to
happen under anesthesia during surgery
everybody has the closure they need I
will do everything in my power to not
have that happen but there's certainly a
possibility with that I think it was a
risk we kind of knew we were going to
have to take we want to do the best
thing for her yeah about having a
crystal ball you don't know you know
[Music]
um
holy cow she's nursing
good job Val great job Iris no
Sue was hungry
I was so hoping for this but I wasn't
expecting it really and to see it happen
it's great now that she's found her
suckle reflex I want her to go home and
start nursing on Mommy because that's
the best good idea a lot of things
contribute to this her electrolytes got
corrected she's got a little more energy
from the fluids yesterday and that
plasma that we gave all those things are
kind of correcting what's going on in
this little calf's body
I'll call Laura and tell her the good
news okay
[Music]
going home
here's Iris guys
[Music]
we missed you oh she looks so much
better
it's like her tongues pulled back in too
and everything figured it out I was
really really relieved and excited to
hear that she took a bottle because it's
just so important for her to get all the
nutrients she needs I just love her so
much there she goes there she goes look
at her
that's a pretty good sight isn't it guys
it's amazing how fast they can go
downhill but it's also amazing how fast
they can get better
[Music]
are you ready yep am I ready this is a
big one we're about to do surgery on z a
12 year old Labrador Retriever who has a
massive tumor on her leg this is no
simple surgery Z's age the size and
location of the tumor her pre-existing
conditions there are a lot of
complicating factors at play this is
Major okay ready let's get it going
monsie yeah I like that
okay numbers look good like every Big
surgery I do them about 100 times in my
head before we actually get to surgery
removing the mass is really the best
option at this point for Z to live the
longest quality of life she can
if we don't do anything I think over the
next few days the only Humane option
would be to put her down
it is time to get this mask off
this is an enormous lump and I know it's
going to be really vascular meaning it
has a large blood supply well we're
definitely going to need more clamps and
crank up our fluids okay is it bleeding
a lot oh horrible oh boy yeah with every
cut we make as we're dissecting this
tumor away from Z there are blood
vessels in positions that we don't know
because this isn't normal healthy tissue
we need to ligate or basically tie off
those vessels so they stop bleeding you
just pouring out of that top right there
you got that side I got this side
how's our collarville still pretty nice
and pink okay
because it is so heavy and so large I'm
going to start from the top down and
start basically cutting it away or
peeling it away from the body so that
gravity is working with us I can slide
my hand behind it there you go whatever
you just did was a big cut
can you lift up and out yeah
it's about to come off guys okay honey
make that big cut
there it is look at that tumor
poor Z
we've got the mass off and everything is
looking good these numbers look great
it's time to close her up
[Music]
looking good hun
oh there you go
that brings that right over just
fine-tuning it right
I gotta go put on new gloves got a
pretty regular rhythm
uh why is everything looking like
for pulse ox is down those are color
oh here comes and our lip are still pink
we're down to 71. she was at 120 a
minute ago
Ben coming what she's down to 67.
I don't know if we're losing her
just as I'm getting ready to close the
up she starts to crash
come on come on come on come on we just
lost everything
this dog is in cardiac arrest and we
only have a few minutes to try and save
her deep bed and waiting for her okay
Val we're gonna need some epinephrine
here we go
you want to go right into her heart
one minute ago she was completely normal
pushing we're trying to do CPR would see
we're breathing for her to try to
oxygenate her we're getting a tiny bit
of a regular rhythm okay
come on
how long has it been since you crashed
two minutes yeah
still nothing
come on
she's been doing fantastic for this full
surgery
no blips on the radar that we were
having an issue and then suddenly we
drove off a cliff no heartbeat
go 10 more and I'll go 10.
it's the worst thing that could possibly
happen when watching this dog die
she's gone
[Music]
this is definitely the toughest part of
our job having an animal die under your
care
energy
it just isn't what we wanted
you know
because he wasn't going to live very
long with this condition and we all know
that her quality of life was going to be
a very poor Aaron stepped up to the
plate and tried to do it
it didn't work
it's hard for me to see Aaron like this
Because We Care for Animals we do these
things to try to help them and Aaron and
I and Val we were doing the best we
could and everything was going great and
unfortunately
it was E's time
[Music]
this is Dr Ben from Cedar County vet
services I actually have some very very
bad news to tell you I'm sorry Z just
passed
I I just feel so bad for you guys
[Music]
I'm so so sorry we almost made it happen
I know she's
not our doggy but we more in the loss of
room I think she was I hope you all can
sleep with the knowledge that she was
pain-free
and Jay Tucker it's like she walked out
on them
the back deck and she turned around and
looked at us and smiled at us as she
left
kind of like I got this guys
well you can tell Z was very loved by
you guys
[Music]
there is a certain amount of faith that
you just have to have that you know when
you did everything and when you did your
best and
we did that as a team to try to save C
and
it just wasn't enough this time
[Music]
how you doing babe
here try some hot tea
this has really been an intense
emotional week Aaron now has lost her
voice
Doris are you giving Aaron a CAT scan
but nothing cheers Aaron up like going
and seeing animals I actually have a job
lined up this weekend the crane trust
down in central Nebraska they wanted me
to come down and look at a couple new
bison that they just Acquired and the
crane migration is going on right now
it's something I've always wanted to do
I know your schedule's clear this
weekend why don't we all go
well good let's pack up the boys jump in
the truck let's get out of here okay
awesome
[Music]
hi guys we made it this is going to be a
great day we get to be outside we get to
see thousands of amazing animals right
here in my home state in Nebraska
Aaron's lost her voice make sure you
disinfect those hands
[Music]
the crane trust is an organization that
maintains and protects a six Thousand
Acre habitat along the Platte River
they've got an extraordinary herd of
bison we're going to check out but first
we need to look at a couple year old
Bison that they want to add to their big
herd
so the crane trust has bison because
bison or a part of the ecosystem they
were a major driver for grasslands
so essentially what we're doing here is
recreating the landscape that would have
once been here
130 years ago bison were almost extinct
and because of conservation places like
the crane trust we're bringing those
numbers back
you ready to do this come on baby
[Music]
they know something's going on bison are
wild animals they're gonna try to get
away
there is a lot of adrenaline pumping
[Music]
the Bulls are really unpredictable
they're mad at everything
[Music]
we got him
first things first let's change that tag
so this was 274
now he's gonna be C1 and that's Charlie
what we always call this Jake the
business end of the animal
it's only 102.4 so that's normal we want
to get some feces from them and make
sure they don't have a big parasite load
we need to treat
we want to deworm them we're also going
to get hair samples for genetic testing
and I think we're ready to let them go
all right let's get ready for number two
here he comes
thank you
[Music]
they backed in
how did that thing turn around
this poor little bison is turned around
right before the shoot I'm not too
worried about him being backwards but
the longer he takes in this facility the
more stressed he's gonna be
[Music]
we're doing health checks on new bison
before they can enter the herd at the
crane Trust
we need him head first in the Chute but
this Bull's got other ideas
they backed in we want the head end not
the butt end
he doesn't want anything to do with
going into our big green crazy shoot
here
again rattle paddle the big baby rattle
is what it is
paddle I bet he turns around
it gets the calf to move because it
hears Some Noise there
got him
this one's now C2 we'll call him Chase
because he's a little stinker
I like working with bison they do get my
heart pumping it is quite exhilarating
for me as a vet to work on this species
of animal
we'll get those fecals ran if everything
checks out these boys will be good to
Join the Herd good awesome if you guys
are interested we can go see the rest of
the herd that would be great
oh give me a home
Where the Buffalo Roam
[Music]
Buffalo is what settlers when they came
here that's what they called them
because they're used to seeing water
buffalo but they're not related to the
buffalo in Africa no
bison is technically their name
they kind of look at you with those big
sweet eyes but boy they could pack a
punch their eyes are big but they're not
sleek
we can't get our hands on all these
animals on this drive through so we've
got to use our eyes
foreign
we're looking for signs of limping bad
eyes and just general body condition
[Music]
Stay Together really well kind of like
cattle yeah the bicycle graze is a unit
if they're away from each other for too
long then they come back then they feel
like they have to fight every time
sounds like these two kids in the back
seat
so this is Patty we bottle raised her
you could pet her
are you kidding no
[Music]
and obviously this isn't something I
would want anybody to do with any bison
Jacob you look like Patty's mother right
Patty's mom yeah
basically mom left and we found her out
on the Prairie by herself and then we
bottle fed her now she's got big horns
so it makes it not fun anymore
this was a lot cuter when she was 50
pounds than
500 pounds
she just has that you know everything is
just so darn cute
[Music]
everybody looks healthy I don't see
anybody that's calving right now Jacob
should we get going yeah I think it's
time bye Patty see ya Patty they're
getting way too close for comfort let me
tell you
now we get to go look at some cranes
yeah
[Music]
we're here in the peak of the crane
migration so this is the Flat River at
its best
[Music]
the crane trust is host to North
America's largest migration which is the
sandhill crane migration oh wow this is
beautiful
you can see forever up here
around a million cranes travel through
an 80 Mile Stretch along the Platte
River in Nebraska on their way North to
their breeding and nesting grounds
look at that they're just flying all
over the place
oh my gosh they're just coming in by the
thousands that is about 300 000 cranes
here right now and a lot more expected
to come in the next few days my my
goodness
it's like they're on the interstate and
this is their rest stop we've had people
all over the world come here only
happens in this 80 Mile Stretch of river
it's beyond special
they're really traveling upwards to a 4
000 mile journey and they do mate for
life so they stop here for about two to
three weeks to turn on the charm find a
mate get healthy and head north for
another couple thousand miles
crane migration checked off of my bucket
list
this has been a heck of a day
it's Trader family do we feel blessed or
what this is amazing thank you so cool
you're welcome anytime
literally
[Music]